jelaine maxwell found guilty in sex
trafficking uh uh trial this is a
guardian story british former socialite
jalen maxwell was found guilty of sex
trafficking or manhattan federal court
trial late december prosecutor said
maxwell
preyed on vulnerable young girls
manipulated them and served them up to
be sexually abused by epstein there were
four accusers in this case jane cade
caroline uh who did not use their full
names and and farmer who did jane
testified that she was 14 years old 1994
when epstein started the sexual abuser
and that sometimes maxwell was present
about uh during the abuse at times max
will participate in the abuse there were
hands everywhere jane recalled of an
encounter with epstein and maxwell the
abuse continued when she was 15 16 max
will face up to 65 years in prison
jelanne maxwell's little black book to
remain secret after judge warns needles
name dropping that's an independent
needless name drop and by the way who
has the black book julian maxwell's
little black book
containing the names and addresses of
nearly 2 000 world leaders leaders
celebrities and alleged victims will
remain secret maxwell's defense attorney
came
to an agreement with a prosecutor over
the weekend not to release the 97-page
directory to the public judge allison
nathan had previously said
she wanted to avoid needless name
dropping during the trial the book was
filled with contact details of miss
maxwell and epstein's famous friends
including prince andrew former's u.s
president bill clinton and trump and had
been mentioned sporadically during her
sex trafficking uh trial so i'm sure
you've been in this world you've been
following the story what do you know
about what's going on here
oh all right i'm gonna try to make this
i'm going to try to make this uh fast
but this is very very nuanced so as an
example the
the black book being sealed right well
that happened back in december early
december the black book is no longer
sealed um it was only sealed in the
courtroom because
the judge didn't want the jury getting
distracted with a bunch of super famous
names
that was really what it came down to
we've actually made this very easy for
everybody you can go to
maxwelltrial.deliverfund.org
and we have posted links to the little
black book which was leaked by gawker
back in 2015. you can you can see it
there you can see the flight logs you
can see all the evidence that was
entered into court and the reason we did
that was to kind of
get rid of some of the conspiracy
theories now the the little black book
what is it the doj has it
uh it was stolen by a uh by the butler i
believe it was who
was essentially using it as an insurance
policy the doj got their hands on it
because the butler tried to then sell it
to an undercover dog
fbi agent uh he ended up getting some
consequences for that
but the the black book was an address
book it's no different than the address
book in your phone right i mean patrick
you've got everybody from cia people to
mobsters in your phone right i mean it's
prior to your
phone everyone had a little black book
right it was called you know yeah
yeah or you know you had your palm pilot
before that or yeah you know
depending on where you are in the the uh
the technology adoption story it was
just an address book so there's all
kinds of people in there who uh some of
them were up to some who were up to no
good and some of them were
doing some pretty terrible things and
some of them were
you know the freaking handyman who
affects the hot water here uh right so
it's
the where we get focused on the little
black book so it's not a ledger it's not
like a this person it's not like the
heidi's
book
no go go it's an address book yeah go
dot it go to
maxwelltrial.deliverfund.org and you and
click on the link that says little black
book but it is pretty interesting what
famous names might be in that book well
yeah like yeah the plumber okay the
handyman your friend but like that's
prince
that's the conversation right prince
andrew's in the book um bill clinton
donald trump alec baldwin i mean yeah
but what's really interesting
don't focus on the black book focus on
the flight logs correct that's what you
want to focus on right and we we posted
a uh uh we posted a link to the flight
logs as well you focus on the flight
logs and who's on there right and and
where they were going so okay we all
know that epstein islands right this
this is not this is not nick's opinion
this is now like fact you're right doj
established fact that there was sex
trafficking happening
within the
uh within the epstein
compound
not just compound but within his
ecosystem
right because it was the london house it
was uh i mean he had the new york town
house right he had multiple locations
within his ecosystem london house yeah
yeah i mean he has uh um he had he had i
mean it places really all over the world
and so the question is
what was he doing
um where'd where what was the source of
his funds
because like tell me what his business
was he was a financial advisor wasn't he
was he
he was a financier he did he was an
executive producer he was a financier of
films and and other projects but that's
one of the things that they can't and
i've read i know where you're going with
this the guy died being worth around 600
million two billion dollars but nobody
knows how he made his money yeah maybe
he's like
financial advisor nancy pelosi does
i mean it's it's a it that's the
question that needs to be asked right
and then if you
where do you get that kind of power
well
what's what don't we know like what
so what here's the question because
everything you just said so far i
followed all the stories so far on what
you what you cover
what don't we know that's important to
know the flight log yep i i agree we
need to know what the flight log is on
who went on there you know all of that
stuff get right there you know with uh
folks that have yeah i've seen this but
what i want to know is what what do we
need to find out next and the
information that we need to find out are
we really going to find out or you know
the other day i saw donald trump jr post
a picture saying you know uh uh uh
jillaine maxwell the day she was born
and then he said two weeks you know like
yeah she's not gonna be here within the
next two weeks so is she gonna plead
guilty the way that uh epstein did
that's right so what's what don't we
know
who's hiding does the government know
what's going on are they holding back
what's going on is there any the you
hear the conspiracies about they're
trying to hold back from people finding
it because a lot of people would go down
what's really going on behind closed
doors so uh
just just because it
so all right conspiracy theories i
yeah you bet there's some powerful
people who are are starting to start to
sweat and uh
to think that we have uh equal access to
the legal system in this country is is
just not true because if you have money
you have more access to the legal system
that's just the way that it works um so
anybody who
anybody who has a lot of money who
might potentially have something to to
be concerned about has the ability to
get in front of that
so like let's not get ourselves into
thinking that they don't
um what is the doj going to do about
that i don't know what we need and what
we don't have or at least what i have
not seen publicly the doj might have
this
is we need a full
financial audit
back to the beginning of time
of epstein's accounts that's what we
need
where did the money come from why right
because i think you're going to see a
decent amount of outflow that's that's
what i want to know i think most of your
outflow is going to be jet fuel right
it's going to be rent it's going to be
those types of things i think most of
your inflow
that's what i'm interested in is where
did that money come from you make a
great point about power you were talking
about power and it's basically
was a
were these nefarious sexual encounters
really the equivalent of x epstein
making bones as the mafia would say yeah
on other people and that became his
labyrinth source of power right because
it all goes like this and so now he's
got control and i agree with you it's
like where did the money come from what
was the money actually used for
you know really used for because the
obvious outflows are going to be
you know service maintenance jet fuel
all the things for all these locations
okay well what was going on
well look at i mean right there uh line
nine on the uh on the flight log right
bill clinton plus four secret service
two males one female
and then a bunch of initials gm skap
yeah so but but there's your point like
all right so what what was happening
there but then go go up um to flight
number 51 and uh cindy lopper yeah go
down the next one right so like
and that's where i think we need no no
no you were on the go go back on the
same page you were at line one yeah
that's where we need to be a little bit
careful on the first page you were on
right there ctrl zoom
51 cindy lopper
and uh
yeah cindy loper and then above that
cindy lopez or maybe that was cindy
lopez and what do they do they go back
and they find the initials and they
identify who that person likely is and
they start questioning those people is
that how it works i don't know what the
doj is doing just because just because
your name is on here doesn't mean you
committed a crime right right but it's
an it's a decent indicator that that
your reserves deserve some questions so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]